do you pray to the gods the old and the
new that is only one God and His name is
death
my impetus here is to keep the story
more realistic if you go back to my
model of the actual Middle Ages our
religion was enormous Lee important I've
been all over the world my boy
and everywhere I go people tell me about
the true gods they all think they found
the right one one of the things we love
what George's worlds are so well and
fully realized there's not one old
religion in one new religion whether
it's the old guys that that Ned Stark
worshipped or the seven gods that count
and Stark worship there are many
religions when you go back into the
history of the Seven Kingdoms the
history of Westeros you find there the
roots of the religions and how each one
has come to be seven have never answered
my prayers
perhaps the old gods will originally
Westeros was the domain of various
non-human races the children of the
forest and they worshiped the old gods
two gods of the trees the gods of the
rocks stones of the mountains of the
streams who had no names there were no
churches or temples and there was no
priesthood and the symbol of them was
the weirwood trees these white trees
with red leaves and red sap so when you
cut them with a knife
they would seem to bleed they became the
center of the religion of the old gods
then at a certain point the first men
came to Westeros the first human beings
crossing from Essos
the first men accepted the gods of the
children of forest in the north where
the Lords are still descended from the
first men the the old gods are still
worshipped Stark's follow up the old
religion Winterfell they have the
godswood
I still feel like an outsider when I
come here you're not an outsider I
wonder if the old gods agree see o God's
with all the rules start to keep the old
God they also have a little cept there
for the seven because lady Catelyn
having come up from the South is a
worshipper of the seven for many
centuries it's been the dominant
religion it was a religion that was
brought over hundreds of years ago by
the hand Allah's the entire religion is
built around the symbology of 7li the
symbol of it is the seven pointed star
seven blessings on you you write the
seven gods are seen to be seven facets
of the One God there are three male
aspects the Father the warrior and the
Smith there are three female aspects
mother the maiden and the Crone and
there's the seventh aspect the stranger
who is neither male nor female and
represents the unknown represents death
and each of the seven aspects of the God
has certain things that they're of
course in charge of you pray to the
mother for a healthy childbirth you pray
to the warrior if you want strengthen
battle may the seven guide her and
protect her on her journey may the
mother give her health may the Crone
give her wisdom they have both male and
female priests were called septons or
SEPTA's they also have the equivalent of
monks and friars who are various orders
one of the most prominent of the silent
sisters who take a vow of silence and
are in charge of dealing with the bodies
of the of the slain once dad my never
done any of it died on the Iron Islands
they follow their own gods the Ironborn
worship the drowned God it's a tough
place and it's a tough religion
seafarers and their God lives under the
sea and they believe that's where their
heaven is they don't fear dying at sea
at all and they don't fear grounding
they drowned they will be taken down
the halls of the drowned God under the
sea where mermaids will wait on them and
they won't feast and frolic for for all
time for worships as a drowned God the
holy water is seawater when you're young
almost as a baptismal right
they actually drowned you and then
you're in court back to life
see unhand that done to him when he was
young just like his brothers did and his
his father and his father's father when
he comes back to the islands having been
away for so long
they're worried whether he's still an
Ironborn I think when Balin first sees
his son he doesn't trust Theon does he
honor our God or has he been converted
to these religions of the green lands my
fears have come true the Starks have
made you theirs my blood is salt and
iron his father insists that he be
blessed with sea water once again the
arm of the house Greyjoy you would this
day consecrate your faith to the drowned
God would that baptism is being
reinitiated into the faith of his
forefathers let's say on your servant to
be born again from the sea as you were
he's saying I'm not a stark and he's
gone back to a drowned God what's he's
dead may never die what is dead may
never die the faith of the Lord of Light
has been unable to get a foothold in
Westeros until recently she's a
foreigner
preach in a foreign religion the
religion of the Lord of Light is
Melisandre's faith for the night is dark
and full of terrors Melisandre is
charismatic priestess from another
country she has powers granted to her by
some divine force she's been there for a
while and she's been trying to convert
Stannis first you must give yourself to
the Lord of life I've said the word it's
very focused on prophecy and on ecstatic
visions that are received through
communion with the flames I have seen
the path to victory in flames
she believes Stannis to be a savior
figure there's only one true God and
that's the Lord of Light so all these
other gods that the people of Westeros
are worshipping that the drowned God on
the Iron Islands the Seven the old gods
they're demons
therefore in Melisandre world view they
have to be destroyed
it's a very black-and-white view of the
universe which rubs many people the
wrong way this is how you treat the gods
of your father's part of accepting the
faith of the Lord of Light is you know
putting all of the Gods aside
ultimately Stannis yields to
Melisandre's and treaties and puts the
seven wooden likenesses of the Gods and
faith to the fire so burning the idols
is getting rid of the seven of paving
way for the new God and of course it's
not just any God it's a god of fire he
is discarding the gods that he has
worships his childhood and accepting the
red God and giving himself to the Lord
of Light and in returned
Melisandre sees that the Lord of Light
gives him a token your sword awaits
role as the prince that was promised by
ancient prophecy and that's the sword
Lightbringer he's able to use the
religion because it means to an end and
of course that end is gaining the Iron
Throne
yeah I'm thrown is mine by right